this planet what's it called
trenzalore hey youtubers its charlie
happy whoo luck week the moment has come
and gone this is my review of the Doctor
Who Christmas special the time of the
doctor just try and not cry I dare you
since a lot of you in the United States
and other international countries might
not have had a chance to see it yet I'll
be careful to provide clear spoiler
warnings in this video but I'll be doing
a separate breakdown of the episode
tomorrow and a Q&A video where I answer
your questions about the episode where
do they'll be super spoilers so be sure
to subscribe to get those videos and
hopefully by then you'll have had a
chance to see it if there's any specific
questions about the Christmas special
that you want me to answer in that Q&A
video tomorrow be sure and write them in
the comments i'm also choosing one
subscriber at random from the comments
to give away a $20 Amazon gift
certificate to if you're an
international viewer that'll just be a
PayPal gift I'll reach out to the winner
in a private Google+ message now cue the
waterworks number one the true field
goes beyond trenzalore this is a bit
meta but Steven Moffat wrote in jokes
addressing everyone's comments about the
thirteenth regeneration and the rule of
twelve and all the other logic problems
that people were asking about I loved
how the doctor literally spoke
everyone's biggest questions out loud as
if to say yes yes we know there's some
issues a lot of fans have complained in
the past that Steven Moffat doesn't care
about canon established during classic
ooh and without spoiling anything I can
safely say that the episode assures us
that he does care and it all makes sense
number two tying everything up with a
nice bowtie most if not all of the major
ongoing plot threads from Matt Smith's
run are tied up going all the way back
to the 11th hour I was so happy to
finally get a definitive answer about
the logic behind some of the more
universe altering events that happened
during the Big Bang namely the TARDIS
exploding and the cracks in the universe
I'll go into greater detail about all
those plot threads and their solutions
in the break down video tomorrow number
three the turkey is done the tone of the
episode was this perfect blend of
sadness and humor I spent most of the
episode in the States somewhere between
crying and laughing out loud but all
throughout there was the strong
undercurrent of hope that moment where
the doctor says I have a plan then
immediately turns to Clara and says no I
haven't got a plan but people love it
when I say that is a
great explanation of how even though
everything you see on screen tells you
something awful is supposed to happen
the doctor can always make you feel okay
about it
number four deus ex machina a big
criticism of some of steven moffat
stories is the deus ex machinist
solutions to the doctors problems the
solution to the siege of trenzalore and
the thirteenth regeneration felt totally
justified to me in this episode what i
mean is the solution flows completely
from the events in the 50th anniversary
episode as well as some of the finer
plot points set up during Matt Smith's
run to be fair it incorporates logic
from series 5 series 6 and series 7 but
including all those bits just makes the
transition from Matt Smith to Peter
Capaldi that much more epic number 5 the
regeneration having made so many Doctor
Who videos this year I thought I was
prepared to see the regeneration but
there was this one moment that just
pushed me over the edge I don't want to
spoil it but there's a very surprise
cameo that made the whole experience
perfect for me I'm still crying inside
just a little bit no not about Matt
Smith but about that moment during the
cameo number 6
welcome Peter Capaldi Peter Capaldi was
on screen for only a few minutes but I
loved it and he utters this question to
Clara that gives you an idea of what the
first couple of episodes of series 8 is
going to be like I also loved the outfit
I'll talk more specifically about that
during my breakdown tomorrow but the
question of a lot of Capaldi's
affectations are largely answered Matt
Smith's changed his outfit several times
from series to series
so Capaldi will obviously change his as
well but I expect that somatically some
of those affectations will hold the same
namely the issue of neck we're careful
for spoilers in my next one I'm going to
be ranking the episode against the other
regenerations and needs to include some
plot points so turn the volume down now
if you need to number 7 ranking the
episode how does it stack up against
other recent regeneration episodes
because the episode was a little more
bombastic than David Tennant and
Christopher Eccleston sendings and we
already knew ahead of time that Clara
would be staying on as the companion in
series 8 it didn't have the air of
finality or the pallor of sadness to it
that those other regenerations had from
an overall satisfaction standpoint I
would rank this episode as my number one
regeneration just
it became the beginning of a whole new
regeneration cycle meaning the doctor
doesn't have that much to lose anymore
he has life to burn which for me is so
much more exciting because it means he
can start taking bigger chances
hopefully the stories told during series
8 will reflect that okay you can turn
the volume back up spoilers over so if
it wasn't clear I loved this episode
obviously it wasn't as emotional as
David Tennant or Christopher Eccleston
for generations but it was much more
exciting one of the hardest things to do
on Doctor Who is to constantly one-up
yourself from series to series and
doctor to doctor
I feel like this sufficiently raised the
stakes without becoming ridiculous I'll
be really interested to see what series
8 looks like with Peter Capaldi and how
they try and top Matt Smith's run I will
be rewatching the episode at least four
times today without spoiling anything
too much my favorite moment during the
episode was actually that cameo that
brief cameo at the very end that was
actually when I started crying let me
know what your favorite moment was in
the comments below I'm sure everyone has
a million questions about the episode
now be sure to leave me your questions
that you want me to answer them in my
Q&A tomorrow I'll also be posting that
super spoilery breakdown of the episode
as well be sure to subscribe to get
everything right now click here to get
my top 11 Matt Smith moments and click
here to get my top 5 Christmas specials
obviously nothing from the current
episode is included in those but thank
you so much for watching Merry Christmas
many happy returns high fives I'll see
you guys tomorrow
you